the promise of this
even though 16 000 even just a subset of
them that's really exciting because then
you can do
as the telescope data get better and
better especially for exoplanets
but also for venus you can then
start like getting your full like you
know how you get like blood work done or
like you get your genetic testing to see
what your ancestors are
you can get the same kind of uh like
high resolution information about
interesting things going on on a
particular planet based in the
atmosphere right exactly
how cool would that be if we could you
know scan an alien planet and go
oh this is what the clouds are made of
this is what's in the surface
these are the molecules that are mixing
here are probably oceans because you can
see these types of molecules above it
and
here are the hadley cells here are
how the biosphere works we could map
this whole thing
wouldn't it be cool if the aliens like
are aware of these techniques and like
would spoof like the wrong gases just
like pretend that's how they can be it's
like an invisibility cloak
they can generate gases that would throw
you off or like
or do the opposite they pretend they
will artificially generate phosphate and
so they
like the dumb the dumb apes on earth
again
like go out like flying in different
places because it's just fun it's like
some teenager
alien somewhere just pranking yeah
uh but i was asked that exact question
this saturday by
uh by a seventy-year-old boy in canada
oh seven
seven yes
[Laughter]
but it was the first time i'd been asked
that question this is the second in a
week
we're kindred spirits him and i we can
um they can prank us to some extent
but the this work of interpreting an
alien atmosphere
means you're reading the atmosphere as a
message
and it's very hard to hide signs of life
in an atmosphere because
you can try to prank us but you're still
going to fart
and breathe and somehow metabolize the
environment around you
yeah and call that whatever you call
that
and release molecules and so that's
really hard to hide
you know you can go very quiet you can
throw out some weird molecule to confuse
us further
but we can still see all your other
metabolites
it's hard to fake
you